uh we turned out to our road to the
Grammy series counting down to music's
biggest night can't wait for it this
morning we have Nate's conversation with
Remy nominee Toby the hip-hop recording
artist and actor is having quite the
year not only is he up for best new
artists this summer he'll also be
featured in the new Transformers movie
and he currently stars in the highly
rated Netflix series Mo P3 State
recently set out with wigwei at one of
his favorite spots in Houston Texas to
talk about his unique sound his laid
back Vibes and Newfound celebrities
I wanted to give you a congratulations
on your nomination Best New Artist come
on Grammy nomination come on the squad
what did you feel when you heard that
news I felt like impossible
if you know hip-hop then you know Toby
wigweh if you don't
you will soon you ready there's a video
of this African runner who it won a race
or something like that and at the end of
the video they asked him about like how
you felt about it I feel exactly like he
did he said I never expected it
I never expected it but God Did It For
Me
born to Immigrant parents from Nigeria
the 35 year old Houston native first
found success on the football field as a
standout linebacker at North Texas
University with the shots at the NFL but
after a career-ending ankle injury
wigwei was thrust into a reality he
wasn't ready to come to grips with it
was the very first time that I ever had
to face who am I outside of Toby the
football player I call it the best worst
injury of my life because my only dream
ever in life was to make it to the
leagues there was a moment where you
talked about your crutches being out of
reach you know you're hitting the floor
I had to do some soul searching in all
aspects of my life my name is Toby and I
can rap really good wickway used music
as an outlet for all that unspent
athletic energy when I'm in my bag I'm
sharpest Cactus shout out to the people
sleeping homie
harnessing it into a popular YouTube
series get twisted Sundays
where he'd freestyle over a beat
like a bad boy I'm trying to get my mama
out there for I just feel like she
looked better in the black horse that's
his wife and collaborator Ivory fat wig
way working on his hair I said all right
cool I'm gonna do something every Sunday
and I'm going to do the absolute best I
can within them six seven days I'm not
gonna make no excuses I'm gonna be
consistent I'm gonna be disciplined I'm
gonna persevere through whatever is
happening in life and it can do it and I
did I've crashed too many beats in a row
for you to think I'm getting lucky you
have been a person an artist that has
been very transparent yes about your
culture yeah about your love your
relationship with your wife and family
why did you make that conscious decision
I just felt way more comfortable being
100 myself in all aspects of my life so
I'm gonna draw from my real experiences
my real life my real situations and I'm
gonna put that into music so that when
you say see me or without or when you
think wherever it's not like oh I gotta
become
Toby the rap right Right Toby the artist
so with no code switch there's no code
switch oh man and there's a freedom for
me
[Music]
you said I put my real life in my music
yes there were some current events that
happened one of them being the death of
Brianna Taylor you were doing something
authentic yeah it went viral why did you
decide to touch on that topic because I
really felt God was like yeah uh
yeah say something about this you put it
to it whatever kind of Beats you need to
put it to but just say it right it was
the first song I ever put together where
I have no rhyming words or nothing it
was literally just the state of arrest
to kill us for Brianna trailer arrested
cops who killed Brianna Taylor everybody
who thinks that you need more evidence
yeah you really goofy
resonating with both fans and critics
the father of three has built the
following largely through social media
without much radio play and without the
support of a major label I've seen for
real because I've been with you that's
my friend you were kicking it with
Chance the Rapper saw you kicking it
with Dave Chappelle I mean this goes on
and on and all these relationships are
truly genuine people have reached out to
me and I've just reciprocated the love
that they've shown people just respect
the art that we put out yeah the type of
people that we are and they fool with us
they really rock with us for me it's
essential just because it's who I am we
spent the day with wig way and his wife
fat walking through the grounds at Bayou
Bend collection and Gardens
it's where they shot the bulk of the
visuals for his latest album moments and
it's on that record where you can hear
some of his musical influences Lauryn
Hill biggie almost every rapper from
Houston I'm taking off down the runway
broad day Sunday and uh late 90s early
2000s how would you describe your sound
you're going to hear some Nigerian
influence you're gonna hear some African
influence you're gonna hear some Houston
influence on my daughters know that this
ain't only talking
you gonna hear some Street trap
influence you're gonna hear some uh yeah
oh you're gonna hear the spirit yeah
you'll hear some solvents yeah
instrumentation it's just a fusion of
my life experiences wickway built his
reputation behind the mic I'm
now he's bolstering that rep in front of
the camera I'm not the one to fear he
was cast in the new Transformers film
due out this summer
and Netflix renewed his hit TV series Mo
for a second season but despite going a
little Hollywood
raps newest renaissance man will always
be Houston I know exactly who I was
before I started doing any of this and
my only advice would be to like hey
before you start getting active figure
out specifically who you are what you
stand for what you stand on once you
have that down Pack Go full fled and
stay consistent stay disciplined stay
focused have a vision and just push
forward
[Music]
I love his message and that's still
pushing forward that that is the
takeaway everyone we feature on this
show who is doing something great will
always say when I found myself yeah and
I started Living that loudly yeah my
career soared yeah everybody can I just
say icons of men's style there right
they were looking great oh kidding on
the grounds or wherever that place was
to Toby I like what I like what Nate
said he will always be Houston everybody
from Houston says that too yeah yeah oh
Toby
thank you not to listen to a lot to look
at too all right tomorrow on our road to
the Grammys series we will talk about
who will win this year's music educator
Grammy Award who's it going to be we'll
reveal the name only on CBS mornings and
of course you can watch the 65th annual
Grammy Awards this Sunday 8pm Eastern
right here on CBS and also on Paramount
Plus